[Musique]
m
roger pigaut bonjour je dis alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui on fait le plat de
viande on va faire un rognon de veau au
giro en j'adore avec un petit gratin de
macaronis tablier tablier viande tablier
vian et les ingrédients alors les
ingrédients on va commencer tout de
suite il me faut donc 250 g de macaronis
deux amis litres de lait 150 g de
gruyère râpé une petite cuillère de
farine du sel du poivre de la muscade
deux grands rognons de veau bien
fréquement boucher va me donner les
petits rognons de veau français 3
cuillères d'huile 100 g de beurre 2
échalotes avec une petites gousses d'ail
simplement pour faire sauter mais même
dit girolles 250 g de girolles 6
cuillères de crème fraîche un petit
verre de cognac un petit peu de vin
blanc sec évidemment du porto et de la
ciboulette et ben voilà on a tout pour
démarrer notre renouveau girolles
vivement que ce soit frais j'ai envie de
manger encore une fois comme d'habitude
quoi faire oui bon on va commencer tout
de suite par notre gratin de macaronis
comme sens intrants qui alors ce qu'il
faut pour faire un beau gratin de
macaronis j'ai d'abord blanchi mais 250
g de macaronis dans l'eau froide
je les fais bouillir 3 4 minutes et je
les ai goûté rafraîchie pour enlever la
fécule la farine qui autour des débats
car audi grande légèreté ce sera moins
pape dans l'estomac
ah bah voilà et après c'est pour ça que
je vais monter un an et demi pour gagner
du temps on l'a mis dans un demi litre
de lait à free alors tu as le lait a été
absorbée par les macaronis ou alors à
mettre de cuillère de crème fraîche mais
hors amm est un petit peu de muscade
ça va m'aider oui je vais attendre
voilà fourchette pour tous liés tout ça
pendant ce temps là elle va me prête un
peu de beurre dans on va brûler
simplement pourquoi que ça accroche
bon j'y vois là mais doit aussi je mets
donc mes yeux ma crème
oui alors évidemment j'aime et du sel là
on va mettre à soupçon de poids parce
que moi j'aime bien le coin monde et je
leur mets à 6 qu'on va le dire le moins
célèbre conte mêlant tous les livres de
cuisine facultatif oui bah maintenant du
poids
voila voila c'est bien impeccable
voilà bien sûr mais alors j'ai pris
comme ça alors ici on va faire quatre
plans puisque c'est pour 4 personnes
mais évidemment on en mettra que doit
gratiné donc c'est bon alors ce qu'on va
faire on va mettre la crème fraîche une
petite cuillère de crème fraîche aux
voix la petite cuillère de crème fraîche
et on va mettre le gruyère râpé
quand on n'est pas obligé de l'étaler la
même façon on n'est pas obligé elle va
s'étaler tout seul
est ce qu'on va faire on va mettre une
petite noisette de beurre
donc là on va les mettre dans l'autre
four chaud alors voilà donc ça doit se
mettre à peu près à four chaud 10 à 12
minutes
eh ben on va s'occuper de nous girolles
alors me gerols on va les faire revenir
avec un peu d'huile
vraiment on va partir de moules voilà il
faut un petit peu d'huile simplement et
la faire chauffer un jour quoi remettre
une arme quand même voilà alors il faut
qu il soit bien chaude
on va attendre directement dans louis à
l'environnement girolles oui elles sont
lavées ah oui bien sûr alors lille a
fait et surtout quand on les lave
il faut que 3 4 minutes après on les
cuisine on savoir s'il faut pas laisser
trop alors lui tient fumant en eau
mais j'adorais naturellement attendre
donc voilà je mets un soupçon
d'échalotes et alors vraiment là c'est
une petite tête d'ail c'est ce qu'elle
vient de le dire une petite bosse die
pardon a vraiment pas beaucoup
simplement pour relever un petit peu je
vais poivrer oui parce qu'on aime bien
le poivre allons-y est salée ça sent
déjà bon oui alors on va simplement met
un petit coup vers comme ça ils vont
rentrer de la vapeur d'eau et ça va donc
la crise un peu dans l'eau alors on va
quand même ralentir pour pas que ça
crame comme un homme alors lire omnium
est pourquoi il est dans le gras alors
le rognon de veau jeu des prix dans le
droit parce que quand vous l'achetez
votre bouche et vous pouvez le demander
à que le gore et ce qui est bien c'est
kate le gras dans le frigo vous le
mettez comme ça dans votre assiette
l'air ne rentre pas et reste frais
pendant trois quatre jours
brandon on va éplucher leurs oignons
lors qu'on les peluches et on en est
simplement le gras comme ça on est
vraiment une carapace evry alors à quoi
on voit qu'à oignons et ferait
évidemment il sent pas du tout et on va
simplement donc le coupé en petits
morceaux très bien alors essayé
d'enlever le plus possible mais on peut
laisser un petit peu de un type quand
même un petit peu de grands quand même
qui va donner ou à la sauce un petit peu
de boue voilà mes champignons on va
arrêter ils sont bons ça se voit tout de
suite qu'ils vont être lui parce qu'ils
vont nuire un peu dans la sens encore
donc je vais arrêter le gaz mais
champignons s'enfuit on n'en parle plus
et ben maintenant ça paraît pas mot
grata nous on va regarder il doit être
commencer un bleu basse à ma main il
commençait au lit on va s'occuper de
leurs oignons et pour cuire leurs
oignons on va mettre un peu de beurre
oui le meur est toujours un petit peu
d'huile
parce que lui il empêche le beurre de
colorer de brûler la maintenance d une
source riche et voila voila savais pas
voilà le beurre et l'huile bien chaud
pas brûler bien chaud comme ça on va
projets nos neurones ion alors les
oignons
on a à peu près 700 grammes de rognons à
peu près un lacet pour quatre ans et
demi à deux personnes
mais voilà on le fait pour 4 alors la
cuisson des rognons la même commande à
moi j'aime bien points bon eh bah bien
lapointe valser à vienne un point alors
on va le cuir un peu coloré quitte à
sortir à un oignon et l'ouvrir et ben
génie commence à colorer alors pour
l'instant génie je ne le savent pas ni
poids vrai il faut d'abord d'abord les
saisir donc les cuire les coloris on
laisse à leur est pas vrai après pour
pas qu'ils ferment leur sens dans tout
le sang va partir si on met le sel on en
pleure regarde y'a qu'la sauf alaoui bin
génie ça commence à vous plaît assez
très bien maintenant là bas je vais
rajouter un petit peu d'échalotes et
c'est maintenant que je vais saler
poivrer
alors ça c'est étonnant on fait tout ça
avant de flamber
avant de flamber et je veux mettre mes
champignons alors aux enfants alors tout
est mis avant avant dames en blanc voilà
un thé magnifique je vais mettre ma
petite cuillère de farine mais un petit
point il faut pas mettre beaucoup
simplement pour lier un soupçon a donc
l'équivalent d'une petite cuillère et je
vais laisser cuire une petite minute ma
farine
pendant ce temps leur arsenic elles
l'ont créée par emma ciboulette parce
que ça paraît pas on va vite arriver à
la fin à la fin et on a faim on a donc
flambé au cognac le tir oignons alors un
petit verre de cognac
oui on met à chauffer et voilà je vais
mettre un petit verre de vin blanc
oui ça aussi un petit verre de porto on
met ça m'étonne pas ainsi si bon et je
vais m évidemment pour finir les deux
petites cuillères de crème fraîche
et ben voilà et on va laisser mijoter
tout menant pendant une ou deux minutes
mes oignons continue de cuir donc
maintenant on va pouvoir déjà allé
chercher nos assiettes on va se préparer
on va dégager un petit peu les assiettes
alors génie regarde bastos mais rognon
sont presque cuit donc je suis en train
de faire réduire ma sauce ici pour avoir
l'eau curiosité parfaite elle commençait
de biens liés aux toujours bien tourner
toujours bien tourné vous voilà on va
pouvoir mettre nos oignons dans nos
assiettes on va bientôt être prêt on va
se rattraper une belle tranche oui c'est
bien attention va d'abord mettre à la
sauce a pris hier à la barre m ca les
assiettes bien chaude évidemment comme
toujours
oui sont chaudes oui c'est un ami me dit
voilà alors je prends maintenant je fais
finir réduire la soeur je vais prendre
une petite louche
j'en ai eu ni si haut que l'organisation
donc évidemment jeu il en restera dans
le plan puisqu'on l'a fait pour quatre
personnes
alors on va saupoudré je saupoudre ouais
alors comme ça alors là c'est le bruit
rognon à kobe trop et je vais sortir
mais grattan nous y reviendrons très
beau au lol c'est beaucoup plus joli
dans un petit plat voilà surtout les
petits plans cuivre ah ça c'est
magnifique
au viol viol au régime au régime ça va
revenir
on va faire à part les régimes hebinger
ni nos petits rognon rouge suivant le
bar à nous reconnaître à y aller
eh ben ça y est on va encore faire bonne
chère
c'est chaud
[Musique]
eh ben
à
ça sent bon alors j'ai mis douter moi ça
avec joie oh
[Musique]
sinon ça me rappelle ma zone est assez
bon tina moi j'entre d'affaires train de
mâcher mois alors on va fé léger dans
les moules alors elles sont croquants
quand même des gâteaux
[Musique]
moi pas
personnellement par evra chaos
[Musique]
le palais
mais l'ironie
[Musique]